the UK is banning adventurous sex the UK
is banning hookups the UK I don't know
it's like they're in Puritan New England
now health protection bill this is about
coronavirus this is about obviously the
pandemic they added on Monday no person
may participate in a gathering which
takes place in a public or private place
indoors and consists of two or more
persons then elsewhere it says no person
may without reasonable excuse stay
overnight at any place other than the
place where they are living the effect
of this they're using kind of
euphemistic language but what they're
saying is don't have sex with people who
you're not already living with and the
fine that can be levied if you break
this rule is a hundred pounds or fifty
pounds if paid within 14 days which is a
pretty expensive romp in the hay the
reason that this law matters I mean I
think it's perfectly fine to curtail
people's sexual adventurism during a
pandemic but the reason it matters is it
shows something that President Trump was
talking about during his Rose Garden
speech about the riots and the chaos and
everything he said that there's a
relationship between liberty and justice
liberty and order and this is something
that we used to know used to be common
sense but now we've all forgotten which
is that freedom is not just being
allowed to do whatever you want all the
time and following your own appetites
actually that's the opposite of freedom
and if you do that for a long time
you're not gonna have freedom for very
long actually the only way you can have
freedom is if you follow the rules John
Adams said this he said our
constitutions built for a moral and
religious people it's not fit to the
governance of any other the thing that
everyone seems to forget is that order
will be imposed there will be order okay
either you can order yourselves and a
free people can run their own families
run their own communities run their own
civic organizations or the government
will impose order on you and that's we
had a lot more of the former in the
earlier stages of our country now we
have a lot more of the latter the only
thing that remains consistent though is
order will be imposed we used to have
in the earlier parts of the country we
used to have a much stricter sexual
morality right so you used to not be
able to just go to the bar and hook up
with whoever and go on tinder and do all
that sort of thing there were there was
a bit didn't mean people didn't violate
the rules sometimes but there was a very
strict sexual morality then we had the
sexual revolution that sexual morality
went away and it was just a our morality
was if it feels good do it but now we're
seeing increasingly the sexual morality
re-imposed in the United States on
college campuses for example that's
reimpose through popular political
slogans like the rape culture the idea
that there is this mass rape going on
that Harvard Yard is more dangerous for
young women than downtown Fallujah which
is obviously not the case but there is a
lot of confusion going on with sexual
engagements so now everything is about
consent you got to sign a consent form
you got to make sure everything's really
buttoned up otherwise you go before
campus tribunal or you get expelled in
the old days you would have been
expelled if you snuck into a girl's room
at night and you guys had a sort of
encounter now you'll be in spell
expelled for basically the same thing
but through a different liberal lens
same thing here in the UK this is this
could be out of Victorian England it's
like history repeats itself
you know maybe first is tragedy then is
force the order will be imposed I think
we would all rather live in a society
where we have some say over that order
where we run our own lives we choose to
follow the rules but if we don't mark my
words this isn't a threat this isn't
just an observation those rules will be
imposed on us and we're not going to
like how it looks when we're all told to
follow
[Music]
[Music]